exclusif Antenne 2 Christian BELAC donne
les derniers chiffres de l'emploi le
budget 78 rigueur et soutien à
l'économie Israël Conseil des ministres
extraordinaires sur l'accord Carter Dian
pr Nobel de physique 77 à de américains
et un
anglais
madame messieur bonsoir avant de
développer tous ces sujets de
l'actualité française je voudrais que
nous jetions un regard sur ce qui se
passe en ce moment au Proche Orient
jamais en effet les chances de paix dura
n'ont été si fortes mais en même temps
si fragiles on s'est beaucoup consulté
de capitale dans capitale on s'est
beaucoup téléphoné et c'est maintenant
au pays du champ de bataille entre
guillemets de décider à cet égard la
journée est décisive pour Israël le
cabinet s'est réuni toute l'après-midi
pour se prononcer sur l'accord d'an
Carter si décisive que le premier
ministre Menen bin encore chancelant est
sorti de l'hôpital pour y
assister il est 9h ce matin menarem bin
quitte l'hôpital de Tel Aviv 11 jours de
repos total après une nouvelle attaque
cardiaque la 3e depuis son élection
connaissent a l'air fatigué encore très
P mais souriant il s'adresse à la foule
ven l'accueillir et au
journalist je remercie mes médecins
ditil ils m'ont permis d'assister cet
après-midi à la session spécial du
cabinet et du Parlement ensuite je
retournerai me reposer c'est tout pas un
mot de
politique en effet la présence de cet
après-midi au Parlement est
indispensablep cabinet doiv se prononcer
sur les dramatiques négociations de
dayane aux États-Unis la crise politique
couvre presque au même moment le général
Diane arrive de New York dans la poche
les dernières positions américaines
encore secrète pour la convocation de la
conférence de Genève mais en Israël même
certains ont déjà accusé Dayan de
trahison il a tropfé diton de concession
aux
AR mais catégorique sa descente d'avion
nous n'irons pas à Genève si l'OLP
l'Organisation de Libération de la
Palestine y est
représenté en fait apparemment une
nouvelle fois l'impass est total même si
bin et son cabinet accepte contraint et
forcé le plan américain il se pourrait
bien que l'ail droite du gouvernement et
du Parlement refuse dans ces conditions
toute participation israélienne à
Genève jaces chabonalmas qui a vu le
premier ministre israélien la semaine
dernière rendra compte de ses
impressions après-demain à Valérie
giscardestin et c'est demain quaraine 2
nous construons au Proche Orient notre
magazine question de temps avec les
reportages de tous les points chauds de
cette nouvelle donne demain donc à
20h30 coup d'envoi du budget 78 défendu
demain par Raymond bar à l'Assemblée
coup d'envoi au pluriel d'abord le
traditionnel avec un échange de vue
entre le Premier ministre et les députés
RPR il faut avoir le courage de faire
une politique à long terme a notamment
dit raymonb ensuite la nouveauté avec un
moyen moderne de présentation des
grandes lignes de ce budget c'est un
moyen que nous connaissons bien à la
télévision l'audiovisuel à l'aide de
diapositiv et de petits films le
gouvernement s'est dit que certaines
idées passeraient mieux qu'au travers
des classiques gros dossiers repris par
les
parlementairire pendant près d'une heure
les membres de la commission des
finances mais aussi les députés invités
ont assisté à la présentation en image
du projet de budget pour 1978 tel qu'il
va être soumis au Parlement à partir de
demain une présentation illustrée avec
des tableaux chiffrés sur les prévisions
économiques les dépenses et les recettes
monsieur Edgar fort le président de
l'Assemblée national a rappelé qu'il
fallait améliorer le déroulement des
débats budgétaires ces débats
budgétaires sont en général les plus
importants de la session ils sont
importants non seulement parce que le
budget propose des actions de politique
générale ou bien des actions
prioritaires dans certains domaines mais
aussi parce que certaines des
dispositions du budget concernent
directement la vie des citoyens à
travers la fiscalité ou bien les
prestations social cette année on ne
prévoit pas de débat budgétair très
passionnés cependant plusieurs projets
fiscaux seront aprement discutés et puis
la commission des Finances estime que le
budget pour 1978 n'est pas un instrument
propre à maîtriser les incertitudes
économiques bref on va beaucoup parler
conjoncture chômage inflation dans les
semaines qui viennent au Palais Bourbon
et peut-êre peut-être un jour quici à
l'aide de la bande dessiné ça nous le
verrons alors maintenant du concret ce
projet de budget en ce qui concerne
notre porte-monnaie et l'économie
générale du pays alors si vous voulez
effectivement concrètement l'économie
générale et puis aussi les citoyens leur
porte-monnaie alors si voulez commençons
par les citoyens et d'abord par les
mauvaises nouvelles ce sont surtout les
automobilistes vous le savez qui vont
payer dans ce budget première mauvaise
nouvelle le prix du super va passer à
2an42 le 1er février de l'année
prochaine et à 2 fr58 le 1er juin donc
augmentation en deux temps augmentation
en deux temps deuxième mauvaise nouvelle
la vignette est majorée de 20 % pour
toutes les cylindrés et de 33 % pour les
cylindrés de 7 à 7 chevaux nous le
savions déjà 5 à 7 chevaux pour le tabac
700 millions de taxes supplémentaires
sont prévu pour les revenus la taxe
exceptionnelle sur les élément du train
de vie et prolongé d'une année mais là
il y a contestation assez forte
semble-t-il au sein de la commission des
finances il y aura probement des débats
à à l'Assemblée sur ce prolongement sur
cette taxe exceptionnel deuxièmement les
députés contestent également
l'aménagement des tranches du barê
qu'est-ce que signifie ce jargon lorsque
vous n'avez pas d'augmentation de
salaire mais que votre salaire augmente
quand même parce que le coût de la vie a
augmenté et bien le fisque lui prétend
ben dit qu'il y a eu augmentation et
vous payez plus d'impôts alors les
députés disent ce n'est pas normal ce
n'est pas juste il faut pas payer
d'impôt davantage parce qu'il n a pas eu
vraiment augmentation et il y a là un
débat assez grand entre les
parlementaires et le gouvernement
discussion dont nous rendons
discion que vous appelez les bonnes nouv
les bonnes nouvelles et bien les
tranches de barê de l'impôt sur les
revenus seront relevés davantage pour
les petits revenus que les gros ceux qui
payent moins de 150 francs d'impôt sur
le revenu n'auront pas à quitter leurs
contribution les personnes âgées
bénéficieront d'exonération plus
importantes et celles qui partent à la
retraite se voit accorder un abattement
spécial de 5000 francs sur leur revenu
imposable afin qu'ell ne payent pas une
fois à la retraite ce qu'elles ont gagné
lorsqu'elles travaillaient enfin les
commerçants les artisans les petits
entrepreneurs et les agriculteurs vont
bénéficier l'an prochain d'un régime
fiscal plus favorable et qui se
rapproche du régime dont bénéficient les
salariés voilà donc pour les mesures
catégorielles s'il fallait résumer alors
écoutez pour résumer si vous voulez il y
a plein de choses à dire vous savez sur
le budget d'abord si on peut montrer ce
sont les dépenses mal les voir les
dépenses 398 milliards de francs et vous
les députés même c'est charmantes petite
fiches et les recettes 390 milliards il
y a donc un toutou de 8 milliards pour
le la première fois vous le savez ce
budget est annoncé avec un déséquilibre
qui dépasse 8 milliards voilà tout en
dessinant le paysage économique de
l'allée à venir de l'année à venir le
gouvernement s'attaque aussi à des
décisions à plus court terme des
décisions qui nous concernent tous aussi
très directement je vais parler de la
hausse des prix alimentaires demain
précisément le comité des prix va se
réunir pour rappeler à l'ordre en
prenant si besoin des mesures plus
autoritaires des secteurs dont les prix
flambettent un peu trop ces derniers
temps dans le collimateur du
gouvernement les fruits et légumes le
jambon certaines viandes et surtout le
café le café l'exemple le plus choquant
sans doute mais aussi le plus
particulier regardez
bien les consommateurs son hab àay CAF
de plus en plus ch la demabica il an 10
Fran en AVR dernier fr enût à FO uneli
ou un préexte l'volution des coursiaux
et pourant depuis 6 Mo cours son en
baisse du coup lesfacteur inv autre
chose l'Ance de le ST ilut pe PRS 3 mois
pour que le café vert aeté sur le marché
international de Londres parvienne
jusquau consommur d'où un décalage
logique des prix mais aujourd'hui ces 3
mois sont largement dépassés et la
baisse volontaire tarde al l'URE la
direction des prix se fâche pour la
deuxième fois en un mois en septembre la
baisse autoritaire du café avait été de
10 % demain le Comité national des prix
devrait annoncer encore une baisse de 6
à 13
%. ce qui est un peu curieux c'est que
quand les cafés ont augmenté les prix du
café ont été bloqués est donc taxé par
nos nos responsables et quand le café
baisse on doit appliquer tout de suite
immédiatement pratiquement la baisse ce
qui est un peu curieux et vous avez
respecté vous la baisse de 10 % temp
bien sûr la baisse depuis
début septembre a été appliqué le café
va encore baisser mais avant de baisser
il faudrait d'abord avoir la marchandise
qui correspond à cette baisse qui n'est
pas encore je dans la plupart des cas
commercialiser sur le marché français et
mon Dieu certains facteurs vont
faire vont être perdants dans dans cette
chose mais enfin la la baisse et n nous
fait
plaisir cela fera surtout plaisir aux
consommateurs et cela mettra peut-être
fin à leur boudderie car selon un
sondage récent en un an 70 % des
Français ont réduit leur consommation de
café la politique maintenant quelques
télégrammes nouvelle mobilisation des
communistes dans le débat sur le
programme commun avec un supplément
spécial entreprise de l'UM dimanche un
appel de Jacques Chirac à Vienne aux
électeurs qui ont quitté la majorité
depuis 74 pour rejoindre l'opposition
revenez à nous a dit le président du RPR
une déclaration d'Alain poè pour son
allocution de rentrée devant le Sénat
nous voulons quel que soit le résultat
de l'élection demeurer un rempart contre
l'aventure et puis la déclaration de
candidature de raymondar dans la 4e
circonscription de Lyon c'est-à-dire la
circonscription que détenait jusqu'alors
le député RPR Louis Jox en fait le
premier ministre qui recev aujourd'hui
le maire de Lyon s'est donné encore 2
jours avant d'annoncer son choix
définitif son choix aussi est celui de
son suppléant nous voilà donc presque
fixés sur la tranchée où raymondbar ira
au charbon pour reprendre sa propre
expression au moment même où un sondage
de l'ifope que publie notre confrère
jeun forme essaie de radioscoper le
personnage bar Premier ministre s'il
faut résumer passe bien dans l'opinion
vous le voyez mais il n'a toujours pas
accompli sa percée politique disent nos
confrères de jeunformme alors pierre
pcier vous venit juste d'écrire un livre
sur Raymon Barch et achè je dois avouer
que nous-même journalistes n'avons pas
toujours pas à cner la la personnalité
du Premier ministre alors s'il faut
résumer bien disons simplement ce n'est
pas un homme politique comme les autres
c'est un homme qui a toujours vécu à
l'écart des milieux politiques mais en
étant dans les milieux politique il n'a
jamais adhéré à un parti il a toujours
été à l'écart des traditions mais
finalement je crois qu'il était
contraint d'être candidat par les règles
de la 5è République car tous les
ministres tous les Prem ministres de la
5e République depuis georgees ppidou ont
été candidats donc d'après vous c'est
pas vraiment un candidat type non c'est
pas le candidat type mais c'est l'homme
qui devait être candidat un peu malgré
lui un peu forcé peut-être qu'il a même
préféré par tempérament aller au sénacer
à l'Assemblée nationale vous l'a dit
dans dans ces moments vous avez pu
l'approcher d'un petit peu plus près
quel type de
caractère outre celui qu'on connaît un
petit peu professoral et bien r bar a un
caractère très très ferme vous le verrez
dans la campagne sera une campagne très
différente de ce qu'on peut attendre
c'est un homme qui n'a pas l'habitude de
cacher ce qu'il pense c'est un homme qui
n'aime pas des choses comme la démagogie
c'est donc un homme qui aura une
campagne très je pense très muselé à
Lyon et qui nous surprendra c'est un
homme qui aime pas parler de sa vie
privée mais vous en savez un peu plus je
dois vous dire que travailler sur un
livre sur la vie de Raymond bar ce n'est
pas facile rayond bar ne m'a pas du tout
aidé j'ai dû faire une enquête de 3 ou 6
mois pour arriver à terminer ce travail
un homme très secret très secret je
crois qu'il d'ailleurs sea à Lyon qui à
la fois une ville économique une ville
gastronomique ça fait de raison de seire
une ville secrète une trè raison je
remcieaair sociales maintenant avec la
nomination d'un nouveau PDG pour France
il s'appelle Jacques petit il a
longtemps été directeur général des
prises uniques au sein du groupe
printemps première décision pas de
licenciement à Manu France le
redressement en entreprise va supposer
de longues négociations avec les
pouvoirs
publics si la situation n'est pas celle
qui a été
décrite si les moyens promis ne
pouvaient pas être obtenus et notamment
l'aide de l'État je me suis réservé de
remettre au conseil d'administration de
France ma démission dans les 3 mois le
cas échéant cette démission serait
acceptée si je le précise c'est parce
que la la nomination d'un nouveau
président n'est pas en soi une
solution il faut en effet agir de façon
à mobiliser les énergies de tout le
personnel de l'entreprise et
particulièrement de son encadrement
c'est à cette condition seulement que
pourront être obtenu les concours et les
apprpris privés et publics nécessaires
au redressement puis au développement de
Manu
France avec nous maintenant sur ce
plateau Christian BELAC le ministre du
Travail nous avons invité monsieur le
ministre pour parler emploi alors quand
est-ce que cette spirale dépressive des
licenciements va va s'arrêter vous savez
que aujourd'hui à l'instant même je
viens d'avoir les chiffres de fin
septembre au point de vue demandeur
d'emplo loi et que nous avons un coup de
frein vis-à-vis du chômage en ce sens
que les chiffres en corrigé de variation
saisonnières c'est-à-dire les chiffres
utilisés par tous ceux qui essayent de
parler de choses comparables à longueur
d'année marquent un recul de sur le août
fin août de - 4,6 % c'est-à-dire que
nous passons de 1 25000 à
1159000 demandeurs d'emploi voilà une
information intéressante que nous
annoncé sur Antenne 2 merci est-ce que
c'est une information qui qui va
s'arrêter est-ce que c'est c'est c'est
un sens général des choses ou à votre
avis juste un petit coup de frein en
fait nous avons plusieurs éléments
positifs il y a celui que je viens de
vous donner qui est important nous
constatons toujours en corrigé de
variation saisonnière une augmentation
des offres de 14 % sur le mois d'août et
nous constatons que les placements de
septembre par rapport à août sont en
augmentation à peu près la même quantité
qu'en 1976 qui était une période moins
difficile sur le plan économique
international seulement d'un notre côté
nous avons des des ombres qui persistent
par exemple d'abord le chiffre des
demandeurs qui reste élevés ceci est
tendu d'ailleurs à l'arrivée des 650000
jeunes qui peuvent pas trouver un emploi
du jour au lendemain et qui d'autre part
d'autre part les entreprises qui ne
commencent que peu à peu à à retrouver
une activité et puis deuxième ombre
c'est le fait que les offres ne sont pas
encore au niveau qu' nous souhait al
monsieur le ministre à quoi est dû ce
coup de frein est-ce que c'est un succès
de votre politique ou est-ce que c'est
un coup de chance j'espère que c'est
l'effet de notre politique vous savez
qu'il y a une mobilisation
exceptionnelle à la fois de
l'administration et de la plupart des
partenaires sociaux ça ne pouvait pas ne
pas avoir d'ffits alors c'est une
victoire je vous ai dit qu'il y avait
des ombres nombreuses et que nous sommes
obligés de nous dire qu'actuellement
indiscutablement il y a un coup de frein
à la à au chômage mais la victoire de
l'emploi doit être encore gagnée et il
faut que tous les employeurs que
l'ensemble des force viv du pays se
mobilise encore plus si possible pour
gagner cette bataille alors je vous avez
été beaucoup aidés par les patrons dans
cette affaireentreise indiscutablement
il y a une mobilisation tout à fait
exceptionnelle que vous pouvez constater
partout est-ce que c'est une
mobilisation politique non je crois
qu'il y a un choix de société bien sûr
car effectivement le problème qui se
pose à nous tous
c'est que il est nécessaire que nos
jeunes puissent s'insérer dans la vie
professionnelle il y a pas de motivation
électorale derrière cela l'espoir de
faire de sauver la majorité comme on dit
croyez-vous que lorsqu'on est devant
650000 jeunes les problèmes d'élection
comptent c'est un problème de société
qui est d'abord est fondamental alors
maintenant monsieur le ministre puisque
nous parlons des jeunes je voudrais que
vous écoutiez ce jugement de la CGT sur
votre campagne sur l'emploi des jeunes
que vous avez lancé il y a plusieurs
mois et que vous intensifiez en ce
moment un jugement je n'ai pas besoin de
vous le dire qui qui n'a rien de très
flatteur il s'agit en fait d'une
campagne bidon il y a en réalité chaque
année 280000 personnes qui quittent
l'activité
professionnelle c'est le départ naturel
et par conséquent pour l'essentiel les
jeunes qui ont été embauchés le temps
d'une campagne électorale puisqu'il
s'agit de contrat à durée déterminée qui
arriveront expiration au printemps de
l'année prochaine ces jeunes remplacent
ne font que remplacer se substituer à
des gens qui quittent normalement leur
activité professionnelle ces jeunes ne
trouveront dans les mesures
gouvernementales ni un véritable
débouché en ce qui concerne emploi ni
une véritable formation il risque par
conséquent à l'issue de ces stages de
courte durée de se retrouver chômeur
c'est-à-dire dans la situation qui est
celle qu'ils connaissent aujourd'hui bon
monsieur le ministre au-delà de cette
affirmation campagne bidon est-ce qu'on
on peut se demander quand même si les
jeunes vont accepter les emplois
proposés ils ont l'air de l'accepter de
les accepter quant aux affirmations de
Monsieur Calvetti c'est une rangaine que
nous attendant depuis fort longtemps
quand vous voyez les premiers effets de
la du Pacte national pour l'emploi quels
effets et quels résultats nous auiion si
Monsieur calvtier la CGT voulaient bien
s'associer à nous c'est regrettable il
demande qu'il y ait de la formation
professionnelle nous augmentons le
nombre de postes de formation
professionnelle dès que nous le faisons
critique je pense que c'est regrettable
et que véritablement vous posiez tout à
l'heure la question tout à l'heure
monsieur Calvetti se sert des jeunes
comme tremplin électoral je crois c'est
dommage est-ce que c'est pas un petit
peu transférer le le chômage vers les
adultes justement puisque une place de
plus pour un jeune c'est peut-être une
place de moins pour un adulte je suis
venu avec les chiffres globaux et dès
que je les ai eu je suis venu vous les
donner en fait c'est demain que nous
allons avoir des chiffres plus précis
dans le détail et qui seront
officialisés ce que et là nous pourrons
voir et apporter un début de réponse ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que nous
avons fait quelques enquêtes et que pour
l'instant l'embauche des moins de 25 ans
continue à peu près normalement bien je
retiens donc de notre conversation ce
chiffre que vous nous donniez tout à
l'heure en exclusivité pour Antenne 2 -
4,6 % pour le chômage au mois de
septembre c'est demain que Paris
accueillera pour une visite officielle
de 3 jours un des derniers si ce n'est
le dernier monstre sacré de l'histoire
yosip Bros Tito le chef de l'État
youoslave hier par l'intermédre
d'Antenne 2 le maréchal Tito s'adressait
au français pour défendre ce qui sera le
thème numéro 1 de ses entretiens avec
Valérie giscardestin la réaffirmation
commune du refus des blocs un sujet dont
les deux hommes avaient longuement
débattu quand le président français
s'était rendu à Belgrade en décembre
dernier et aujourd'hui George Bortoli
qu' connait bien nous retrace les grands
moments de ce qui est déjà la légende
dit
au début du siècle le futur Tito n'est
encore que l'ouvrier métallurgiste yosip
Brose né croate il est donc à cette
époque sujet autrichien ce qui lui vaut
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale
d'être fait prisonnier par les Russes et
d'assister en Russie à la révolution
d'octobre
1917 le spectacle de cette révolution
l'impressionne
profondément quand il rentre dans sa
Croatie natale devenue en 1918 partie
intégrante d'un pays nouveau la
Yougoslavie il adhère au Parti
communiste et première conséquence il se
retrouve en prison car le Parti
communiste yougoslave est alors interit
puis il gravit rapidement les échelons
devient secrétaire général de son parti
un secrétaire général clandestin qui se
cache sous de faux passeport ici il est
un ingénieur
suédois pendant la 2è guerre mondiale
yosip Brose sous le pseudonyme de Tito
organise les partisans communistes
youoslaves
en 1944 les Alliés reconnaissent déjà en
lui le maréchal
Tito son armée de partisans est devenue
une armée régulière il entre dans
Belgrade libéré en
triomphateur dans la guerre froide qui
commence à s'installer le maréchal Tito
est résolument du côté des Soviétiques
et puis en 1948 l'impensant se produit
Tito défi Staline et c'est Tito qui a le
dernier mot car c'est krutchov qui
Staline mort vient présenter à tit les
excluses
soviétiques Tito a inventé le
nonalignement être en bon terme à la
fois avec l'ouest et avec l'Est il
réunit à Belgrade la première grande
conférence des non aligné avec toutes
les vedettes de l'époque des pays en
voie de développement depuis le nus éien
jusquà Nasser et
nou cette politique de non alignement
Tito la poursuivra avec acharnement se
payant même le luxe il y a quelques
semaines encore de se rendre
successivement à Moscou et à Pékin de
capitales pourtant en principe
irréconciliable tel est l'homme hors
série qui gouverne la Yougoslavie depuis
plus de 30 ans le 25 mai dernier la
jeunesse youoslave lui a souhaité bon
anniversaire c'était le
85e madame Tito était au côté de son
mari dans la tribune mais depuis elle ne
l'a pas accompagné en Chine et il semble
qu'elle ne l'accompagnera pas non plus à
Paris ce qui a suscité quelques rumeurs
sur son état de
santé on a remis à Tito un témoin
apporté du fin fond de la Yougoslavie de
ce pays dont il est resté le sa
d'unité autre chef d'État l'Élisée cet
après-midi le général mobutou le
président de la République d'useille
notre confrère Yve de chazourne envoyé
spécial du ctidien de Paris aux
Philippines vient d'être relâché après 6
jours d'internement pour avoir visité un
camp de guerria musulmane dans le sud du
pays après après le prix Nobel de la
Paix hier le Nobel de physique et de
chimie aujourd'hui chimie le professeur
Prine de l'Université de Bruxelles
félicitations donc à nos amis belges et
puis la physique à deux Américains et un
Britannique Anderson mot et vanelk
ordinairement il s'agit surtout de
récompenser des théoriciens mais là vous
allez le voir la théorie devient très
vite pratique les trois hommes ont fait
faire je crois un gros bond à la
science télécommunication radio
ordinateur fusé tout dépend de
l'électronique or ce domaine de la
physique est en passe d'être bouleversé
par les découvertes des trois prix Nobel
jusqu'à présent seul des cristaux bien
réguliers bien organisés entrent dans la
composition des appareils électroniques
votre poste de télévision par exemple
mais l'ordre parfait de ces éléments
coûte très cher et si le tout venant
suffisait si de simples ver pouvaient
remplir les mêmes fonctions et bien les
chercheurs sont parvenus à dominer le
désordre voire même l'anarchie de ces
matériaux en verre dès lors leurs
applications se sont multipliées depuis
des mémoires pour ordinateur à la plus
petite caméra de télévision du monde
mais l'espoir réside ici dans les
cellules solaires fabriqué à grand frais
à partir de silicium cristallin les
cellules actuelles ne sont pas rentable
d'ici 3 ans des vers pourrai les
remplacer le prix des cellules serait
alors divisé par 100 ou plus cette
nouvelle génération de cellules
placeraient l'énergie solaire au premier
rang des énergies propres les trois prix
Nobel n'imaginent sans doute pas il y a
plus de 15 ans lorsqu'il débutai à leur
recherche théorique que leur découverte
allait peut-être un jour recouvrir le
toit de toutes les maisons
encore un détournement d'avion un avion
des lignes intérieures tchchoslovaque
qui reliait Carlo Vivari l'ancien
carlsbag à Prague a été détourné donc ce
matin sur Francfort l'atterri l'avion a
atterri à Francfort pardon et les
pirates de l'air ont demandé l'asile
politique en République fédérale
allemande pas de réponse pour l'instant
des autorités
locales une fois de plus le tabac en
accusation et c'est peut-être bien le
responsable de mot dont on avait chargé
la pilule vous saveit on avait dit que
la pilule contraceptive pouvait être la
cause de quelques accidents
cardio-vasculaires et si l'on en croit
les deux rapports que vous venez de lire
Martine alin rot et bien je crois que
finalement c'est le tabac qu'il fallait
incriminer oui tabac plus pilule c'est
la conjonction des deux alors deux
enquêtes anglaises l'une portant sur
46000 femmes l'autre sur 17000 femmes
suivies pendant plusieurs années montrre
que finalement les accidents
cardioovasculaires au demeurant fort
rare n'ont lieu que chez des femmes qui
ont plus de 35 ans qui ont pris la
pilule pendant plus de 5 ans pilulle
contraceptives bien entendu et qui
fument qui sont de grandes fumeuses
alors la conclusion des Britanniques est
très simple pas de panique car il y a 50
ou 60 décès pour 70000 femmes mais
suffisamment de chiffres quand même pour
faire attention alors il conseille aux
femmes qui fument et qui n'ont pas
l'intention de cesser de changer
doucement tranquillement de méthodes
contraceptives je crois qu'ils n'ont pas
tort et la raison médicale qui entraîne
la raison biologique qui fait ça et ben
on a cru comprendre et on commence à
étudier ce phénomène que la nicotine
contribue à laéser la paroie des artères
et lorsqu'une paroie est laésée elle
recueille plus facilement un caillot
quand le sang est plus visqueuse qui
arrive avec l'âge avec certaines
prédispositions le caillot se forme aux
endroits lésés alors si les nicotine
aide fatalement ça va mal je vis
maintenant remercier tous ceux qui nous
avaient envoyé de très nombreux
témoignages à la suite de l'appel que
nous lancions pour composer une émission
sur la mort le 2 novembre vos lettres
nous ont été très utiles nos services
les ont regroupés pour aider à une
véritable étude statistique sur sur la
façon dont les uns les autres avaient pu
percevoir votre propre mort écrivez-nous
encore si vous avez ressenti des
impressions dans ces moments qui
avoisinent la mort si vous avez connu ce
que l'on appelle la mort clinique ou un
très long Comat d'avance merci je crois
que notre émission du 2 novembre n'en
sera que meilleur toute transition
serait absurde mais je vous invite à
regarder ces images assez étourdissantes
elle nous viennent de Nice où le
cascadeur Eddie selevan vient de battre
un record du monde
regardez bien cette petite voiture avec
elle s lanant d'un trempelin de 8 m il
va franchir plus de 80 m
81,25 très précisément record du monde
battu et il va s'en sortir sans le
moindre
bobo et pour en revenir à un sport moins
dangereux le football avec une nouvelle
soirée de championnat la 11e tous les
résultats à 23h30 dans le dernier
journal de Gérard Holz après de
passionnants Dossiers de l'écran
consacré à Jean-Moulin auparavant quand
même la météo et bien demain matin le
temps sera très nuageux avec quelques
pluies sur l'ouest du pays une zone
pluvieuse qui devrait s'étendre vers
l'est vous le voyez dans la journée seul
l'extrême Est sera favorisé voilà je
vous souhaite à tous une très très bonne
soirée à l'écoute de nos programmes à
demain
bonsoir